this week's 48 hours investigates the
unsolved murder of a young girl decades
ago in the idaho man who's in the center
of the case janelle matthews was just 12
years old in 1984 when she disappeared
from her home in colorado the case
remained cold for decades until her body
was discovered in 2019. more than 36
years after janelle vanished stephen
panke went on trial for her murder
authorities say he incriminated himself
penke's attorney says his client had a
strong interest in the case but that
doesn't make him a murderer 48 hours
correspondent richard schlesinger has
more
nearly four decades after janelle
matthews was kidnapped and killed
opening statements began in her murder
trial for 37 years justice for janelle
has been denied that change is beginning
today it was 1984 just five days before
christmas when janelle vanished from the
matthews home in greeley colorado the
only physical evidence discovered by
police were a stranger's shoe prints
left in the snow
shoe prints that someone tried to erase
with a garden rake says janelle's father
jim matthews right out of my garage it
wasn't until 2019 when janelle's body
was finally found that police were
suddenly questioning a person of
interest in idaho a man they say knew
about those raked footprints i humbly
ask for your vote he's a former
candidate for sheriff and governor in
idaho and a one-time resident of greeley
stephen panke
we had never heard the name before that
but for years stephen panke had been
suggesting to authorities that he might
know what happened to jenelle and that's
what got him charged with her murder i
knew more than i wanted to know okay but
defense attorney anthony viorst says his
client is innocent he's a talkative guy
but he's not a murderer it was just
me trying to
be a big man be in the case okay i had
no knowledge panky is so talkative that
he took the stand
i was thanking god
maybe i shouldn't testify because i'd be
just telling more lies after two days of
deliberations the jurors announced they
were split and could not convict stephen
panke of kidnapping and killing janelle
matthews
richard schlesinger joins us now richard
why did the jury come to this decision
and do you think they'll retry them
the state wants to retry them uh panky
is still in jail and
no trial date's been set but they have
announced that they plan to retry them
this had to have been a terribly
difficult case for the jury there was no
dna dna technology hadn't been
developed at that point
and the the defense
presented another possible suspect a guy
who was in the neighborhood around the
time that janelle disappeared and
himself reportedly went missing around
the time janelle disappeared so they had
a lot to deal with
he didn't seem to hope his case either
you know even his own attorney admits
that he was a bit of a chatty kathy
you know i i've said to my colleagues a
few times being this guy's defense
attorney had to have been the most
difficult job in the world panky loves
to talk i mean he's given interviews
over the years
and that's really what got him into all
this trouble
richard before we go we wanted to talk
to you about a recent death in the
family the cbs family someone on the 48
hours team josh gellman what can you
tell us about him i know just now we
were talking about him in the studio and
someone just said brian specifically
said he's one of the good ones he was
one of the good guys
he was one of the great guys um thanks
for asking gail uh his uh his title was
producer but that didn't describe him
even a little he was one of those guys
whose mind was always clicking whether
he was working or playing a lot of the
visual magic that you saw in 48 hours
came out of josh's brain and a lot of
those great human stories came out of
his heart he was also just a great
friend with a razor sharp wit
he made our stories better he made our
lives better especially the lives of his
wife christina
and his their daughter eva
uh josh was just a one-of-a-kind great
guy we will miss him
miss him terribly we were privileged to
know him thanks for asking him wow it's
a beautiful remembrance that's a yeah
beautifully said about him i was very
sorry to hear it and certainly we're
thinking about his wife and his daughter
at this time it's very tough to get that
news this week
thank you richard thank you very much it
is thank you you can watch richard's
report you're welcome you can watch
richard's report on 48 hours it's
tomorrow night at 10 9 central right
here on cbs we'll be right back